สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนนะคะเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่กันนะคะ
ครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้นะคะที่นี่นะ
ที่อเมริกา
นะวันศุกร์ครับ
เอ้าขอ
วันนี้วัน
ศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ครับเดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
25  6  5 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้ที่บ้านครูนิกเนี่ย
เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้นะครับที่ครูนิก
อยู่นะ
59 นาที
อุ้ยอีก 1 นาทีก็ 20:00 นแล้วนะคะครูนิก
ใช่ 20:00 นแล้วครูนิกจะนอนหรือยังคะจะ
20:00 นแล้วนอนหือยังคิดว่ายังคิดว่ายัง
เพราะปักเนี่ยครุณนิกน่าจะนอนประมาณ 22:00
น 23:00 นอืครับก็อีกประมาณ 23 ชมงอืใช่
เ้าๆแล้วครูนิกทำอะไรอ่ะคะถ้าไม่นอนเออ
ทำไมไม่นอนทำไมไม่นอนก็ต้องนอน 22:00 น
คือจริงๆอ่ะปกติเนี่ยตอนกลางคืนน่ะคุณนิก
อจะดูหนังดูละครหรือดูซีรีส์กับแฟนคุณ
ก่อนนอนออือดูแบบพวกสมิอย่างเงี้ยรอคะแบบ
netflix ใช่อะไรบ้างนะไม่รู้เนาะ Disney
Plus  hbo ใช่คือที่อเมริกาเนี่ยมีเยอะ
มากแต่อที่ครูนิกดูบ่อยๆก็จะดูใน netflix
แล้วก็ของ Amazon
อืแล้วถ้าอย่างถ้าดูใน netflix เหรอซอ
เนี่ยน่าจะไม่ใช่หนังไทยละครไทยซีรียส์
ไทยก็น่าจะไม่ใช่เนาะไม่ไม่ใช่ครับคือครู
นิกเนี่ยจริงๆเี่คครูนิกอ่ะไม่ไม่ชอบดู
ละครไทยไม่ชอบดูที่ไทยอคือต้องต้องบอก
ก่อนว่าทำไมถึงไม่ชอบคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
เมื่อก่อนชอบ
ดูชอบดูไม่รู้ว่าครูหญิงเคยดูมยเรื่อง
เนื้อคู่ประตูถัดไปไม่เคย
ดูจริงๆเราก็อายุไม่ห่างกันนะคือมันเป็น
ช่วงที่ที่ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ดูแล้วไงไม่ดู
ละครแล้ว
อ่าคืออันนั้นเนี่ยเป็นเป็นก็เป็นซีรียส์
ไทยที่ครูนิกอ่ะชอบดูมันตลกดีเดี๋ยวูหญิง
เปิดให้นักเรียนดูนะคะครับอันนี้หรอันนี้
ใช่ไหมคครูนิกเดี๋ยวลองเปิดให้ดูก่อนคือู
หญิงเคยได้ยินนะู้หญิงเคยได้ยินละคร
เรื่องนี้เนาะใช่มั้ยคะนี่ใช่อันนี้แหละ
ครับออันนี้อันนี้สนุกใช่มั้ยน่าจะคล้ายๆ
เป็นิคอมมั้ยคะหรือไม่ใช่คอใช่จริงๆก็
เป็นิอใช่ๆๆมันตลกนะมันเป็นมันเป็นเหมือน
เหมือนซคอมตลกเราก็ดูแล้วเราก็ชอบเมื่อ
ก่อนนะครับค่ะใช่แปลว่าแต่ที่ครูนิกชอบดู
เรื่องนี้เนี่ยเพราะว่าครูนิกชอบปุ๊กกี้
อ้าใช่แต่เขาไม่ได้อยู่ในรูปที่ครูหญิง
ไม่อยู่ขึ้นมาให้ดูอือเอารูปนี้มยครูหญิง
คิดว่าต้องมีเ้าแน่
ๆเดี๋ยวครู้หญิงให้คือแปลว่าครูนิกดู
เรื่องนี้เพราะว่าชอบคนที่เล่นใช่่คนนี้
กุ๊กกี้คือคนที่ใส่ที่คาดผใส่้าูใอ่าคุณ
นี้ใช่มั้ยคะครับใช่ออครูนิกชอบนักแสดงคน
นี้คนที่ชื่อปุ๊กกี้ก็เลยดูใช่ิคอมเรื่อง
นี้ทำไมชอบเค้าอ่ะคือคนิกอ่ะชอบเพราะว่า
เค้าตลกดี
อ๋อใคือเา้าจะเป็นคนคือจริงๆเนี่ยในใน Sit
คอมนี้เนี่ยเค้าเค้าไม่ใช่คนตลกแต่ว่า
เวลาเขาจะทำอะไรเนี่ยคุณนิกดูแล้วมันขำ
อ่าคืออ๋อโอเคเข้าใจเข้าใจเข้าใจค่ะครับ
อ๋อก็ถ้าอย่างงั้นน่ะเวลาครูนิกจะดู
ซีรีส์ดู
หนังดูอะไรใน netflix หรือว่า Amazon
อย่างเงี้ยครูนิกก็เลือกดูจากนักแสดงที่
ครูนิกชอบเหรอคะใช่ครับใช่อืแล้วครูนิกมี
นักแสดงแบบฮอลลิวูดหรืออะไรเงี้ยหรือดารา
อเมริกาที่ครูนิกชอบแล้วก็แบบถ้าเขามี
หนังมีซีรียส์ครูนิกเนี่ยต้องดูไม่ดูไม่
ได้มีมั้ยคะมีครับก็จริงๆแล้วเนี่ย
เวลาคูณนิกจะดูหนังหรือดูซีรีส์เนี่ย
อย่างแรกก็คือดูนักแสดงอืว่านักแสดงที่
เราชอบมีมยถ้ามีก็จะดูเลยอืเรื่องอะไรก็
ได้ที่มีคนนี้เล่นค่ะก็จะอยู่ของคครูนิก
เนี่ยที่ชอบก็คือชอบ
เอ่อนักแสดงของนักแสดงอเมริกันเป็นผู้
หญิงชื่อ Mer  stp คือคนที่เรื่อง Devil
W  Prada อใช่ๆค่ะคุณหญิงเคยดูเล่นเเล่น
เรื่องนั้นกับมาม่าเมียมั้งอือ่ามาม่า
เมียมาม่าเมียคุณนิดก็ชอบมากอืใช่ค่ะอ๋อ
ถ้าเรื่องไหนคือหนังหรือว่าซีรีส์เรื่อง
ไหนที่ Mer  streep เขอชื่อนี้ใช่มั้ย Mer
streep เล่นครูนิกเนี่ยก็จะดูใช่ใช
อืแล้วคุณนิกเลือกดูจากอะไรอีกคะนอกจาก
นักแสดงแล้วจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยก็นักแสดงคือ
อย่างแรกอย่างที่ 2 เนี่ยครูนิกจะชอบดู
หนังที่ถ้าเป็นหนังนะคุณนึกจะชอบดูหนัง
ที่ได้รางวัลอย่างรางวัลออสก้ารางวัลเอ่อ
จากฝรั่งเศสที่เรียกว่าเหมือนกับเป็น
รางวัลคานที่มาจาก
ออใช่ครับหรือว่าแบบอะไรนะเอมี่ถ้าทีวี
มันจะมีอะไรนะคะแบบอก้ามันจะเป็นไเอี่นะ
ถ้าจำไม่ผิดเอี่ award อย่างี้เหรอใช่ใช่
อืครูนิชอบดูหนังรางวัลหรอใช่คือต้องเป็น
หนังนะแต่ถ้าเป็นทีวีเป็นซีรียส์
เนี่ยถ้าซีรีส์ก็จะแค่ดูว่าเป็นซีรีส์ตลก
แค่นั้นเองอืคือคือครูนิกชอบดูหนังรางวัล
เพราะว่าเวลาดูหนังเนี่ยครูนิกคิดว่าอยาก
ดูหนังที่ทำให้เราต้องคิดตามไปด้วยไม่ใช่
หนังฮอลลีวูดที่เมื่อก่อนคนไทยก็จะบอกว่า
เป็น Happy  Ending ดูๆไปอ่ะถ้าผู้ชายผู้
หญิงเลิกกันเดี๋ยวมันก็กลับมาเพราะหนัง
ฮอลลีวูดอ่ะมัน Happy  Ending อยู่แล้วออ
คุณนนี่ก็คือจริงๆคนไทยเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่นะคะ
ถ้าเป็นหนังที่ได้หนังที่ดีๆอ่ะเนาะหนัง
แบบครับบางครั้งอเมริกาคือมีหนังเยอะมากๆ
แต่คนไทยเนี่ยจะได้ดูแบบหนังอ่ะถ้าเป็น
ดาราก็คือบรูส Willis  the  rock ใช่มั้ย
ตอนนี้หรือว่า will  smit อย่างเงี้ย
อันเนี้ยหนังของนักแสดงเหล่าเนี้ยคนไทยจะ
ได้ดูแล้วก็จะเป็นหนังที่แบบ Box อฟฟิศ
หน่อยมยคะหนังที่ดูง่ายๆ่าง่ายๆไม่ต้อง
คิดไม่ต้องคิดอือๆอืแต่ครูนิกเนี่ยชอบดู
หนังที่แบบต้อง
คิดใช่ต้องคิดเยอะๆหน่อยคือจริงๆเนี่ยตอน
ที่ครูนิกเรียนที่มหาวิทยาลัยเนี่ยคือครู
นิกอ่ะเรียนครูนิกเรียนฝรั่งเศสแล้วมันก็
จะมี 1 ปีที่เป็นวิชาเกี่ยวกับหนัง
ฝรั่งเศสอื
โอ้โหเป็นยังไงคือคุณนิกดูหนังฝรั่งเศส
แล้วเป็นการเปิดโลกครูนิกมากเพราะทำไมอ่ะ
มันไม่เหมือนหนังที่ครูนิกเคยดูมาก่อนก็
หลังจากที่เรียนวิชานี้เนี่ยดูหนัง
ฝรั่งเศสนี่แหละทำให้ครุนิ
เปลี่ยนการดูหนังว่าถ้าเป็นหนังจาก
อเมริกาจะเป็นหนังที่ได้รางวัลแล้วครูนิ
จะดูเพราะว่ามันมันมีเรื่องที่มันไม่ใช่
ง่ายๆมันจะมีอะไรซับซ้อนแบบหลายหลายอย่าง
รวมๆกันคือหนังฝรั่งเศสเนี่ยเา้าจะเป็น
หนังที่เาจะคนไทยเหมือนกับจะเรียกว่าเป็น
แบบหนังจบแบบปลายเปิดอืมก็คือคิดเองว่า
เป็นยังไงใช่
อืยกตัวอย่างครับเหมือนกับว่าอา้าง่ายๆนะ
เป็นในในหนังเนี่ยผู้ชายผู้หญิงเป็นแฟน
กันแล้วพอผู้ชายผู้หญิงเป็นแฟนกัน 1 คืน
เค้าทะเลาะกันพอเค้าทะเลาะกันเสร็จอยู่ดี
ๆผู้หญิงเก็บของแล้วก็ออกจาก
บ้านแล้วหนังก็จบ
ะูหญิงเคยได้ยินมานะว่าหนังยุโรปเนี่ยเขา
จะมีความไม่เหมือนหนังอเมริกาเลยใช่่ใช่
มันจะดูจริงๆคนไทยจะบอกว่าเป็นคนไทยจะพูด
ว่ามันจะดูเป็นหนังอินดี้
เออมันมีความเป็นอาร์ตอินดี้ที่
แบบคผู้หญิงดูแล้วคงแบบเออทำไมเราต้องดู
เรื่องนี้ด้วย
ทำไมมันจะแบบคือเราจะไม่ชินคนไทยจะไม่ชิน
แบบอ้าแล้วตมีตอนตอนที่ 2 มยหรือจบแล้ว
แบบเนี้ยเออนั่นแหละทำไมค่ะครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ดูเลยนะคะครูนิกรู้
มยอ้าวเดี๋ยวอ่ะแล้วปกติครูนิกเอ้ยไม่ใช่
คุณปกติครูหญิงเวลาจะดูหนังดูซีรีส์นี่
คือดูยังไงครับจริงๆนะครูครูหญิงเนี่ยอ่า
ถ้าดาราที่ชอบอครูหญิงไม่ได้มีขนาดนั้นนะ
คะครูหญิงเนี่ยจะดูเลยก็คือหนังของฝรั่ง
เนี่ยเขาจะมีเรทเรทอายุครับอ่าว่าอายุ
เท่าไหร่ดูได้แต่จริงๆครูหญิงก็คือดูดู
ได้ทุกเรื่องนะคะอ่าแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยจะดู
เรทหนังประมาณอายุ 16 ลงมาอถ้าแบบ 18
หรือว่า 20 หรือว่าเรท R อย่างเงี้ยไม่
ดูทำไมอ่ะมันชอบระเบิดไงคุณนิแบบว่า
สมมุติมีมีดอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็เออ๋อเออครู
หญิงเนี่ยดูไม่ได้มันน่ากลัวออจะรู้สึก
ว่ามัน
แบบทำไมมันแบบสมมุติอ่ะบางเรื่องอย่าง
เงี้ยทุบทุบทุแล้วก็เ้ออย่างเงี้ยก็จะไม่
ค่อยดูอืคือเราจะรู้สึกว่าอ่ะถ้ามันซัก 16
ยังโอเคหรือว่า
13 เงี้ยดูได้มันจะไม่มีรูปไม่มีภาพอะไร
ที่แบบน่ากลัวครับอ่าใช่คือคุณนิกาโชคดี
เอ๊ะจะเรียกว่าโชคดีมั้ยโชคดีว่าเมื่อ
ก่อนตอนเด็กๆเนี่ยครูนิกอ่ะจะชอบดูหนัง
คุณจะชอบดูหนังฆาตกรรม
อ๋ออย่างเช่น
แบบจริงๆครูหญิงอ่ะชอบนะครูนิกอเมริกาจะ
มี 1 ซีรีย์ที่เกี่ยวกับฆาตกรรมก็คือ
Criminal  mind ก็ฆาตกรรมมั้
fbi คือ Criminal  mind ใช่ก็มีฆาตกรรม
แต่มันจะเป็น fbi ที่สืบสวนอ๋ออเออใช่ๆ
ตายแล้วแล้วอ๋อตายแล้วใครเป็นคนฆ่าแต่ของ
ครูนิกเนี่ยจะเป็นเหมือนกับฆาตกรรมยกตัว
อย่างคุณูหญิงคงไม่เคยดูแต่อาจจะเคยได้
ยินเอ่อตุ๊กตาผี
ชักกี้หรือหนังหนังฝรั่งที่ชื่อสกรีมที่
เป็นผีหน้ากากยาว
เดี๋ยว Final  destination อย่างงี้มั้ย
คะครูโอ้ชอบ
ใช่โอเคเราเข้าใจไม่เหมือนกัน
แล้วคือแต่ตอนเด็กๆตอนเด็กๆประมาณ 15  10
ประมาณ 10 ช่วง 12 ถึงเอาง่ายๆมต้นถึงม
ปลายจะชอบดูหนังแบบนี้มากอย่างศุกร์ 13
ก็ชอบโอ้โหเ้าอย่างงี้แบบพวกเทกซัสเนซ
อะไรอะไรอย่างงี้โอ้โหดูใช่โอเคค่ะเมื่อ
ก่อนตอนนี้ล่ะตอนนี้ไม่ดูแล้วเหรอคะหนัง
แบบคือตอนนี้เนี่ยถ้าเลือกได้จะไม่ดูอื
อือใช่แต่ก็ดูได้แต่ก็ก็ดูได้ก็
ถ้าถ้าเป็นหนังที่มันมีฉากแบบนี้นิดหน่อย
มันก็โอเคหรือถ้ามีคนสู้กันแล้วมีตัดคอแอ
เลือดเอออหนังเรื่องนี้ก็ชอบมากชื่อ
เรื่องคิวบิวอ๋อคิวบิวคิวบิวคุณหญิงไม่
เคยดูเลยอ่ะไม่เคยดูแต่ีเรื่องเนี้ยครู
นิกชอบเพราะครูนิกคิดว่ามันมันเป็นเรื่อง
ที่ดีแต่ว่ามันก็มีสู้กันแล้วก็มีฆ่ากัน
เยอะใช่อืคือถ้าแบบคุณนิกบอกอย่าเงี้ยฆ่า
กันธรรมดาอย่างเงี้ยโอเคดูดได้แต่ถ้าขอ
โทษครับทุบไม่เป็นไรค่ะทุบทุทุอยู่เงี้ย
แล้วก็แบบสมอง
ระเบิดเออๆอันเนี้ยครูหญิงดูไม่ได้นะคะดู
แล้วเวลานอนเนี่ยโอ้โหหฝ่าใช่เห็นใช่ครู
หญิงก็เลยส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยจะเลือกดูจากตรง
นี้แล้วก็คะแนนเนี่ยอ่าบางครั้งเนี่ยคน
ไทยก็อาจจะเลือกดูจากคะแนนใช่มั้ยมันจะมี
เว็บไซต์ร Tomato อืว่า 100 คะแนนหนัง
เรื่องนี้ได้กี่คะแนนครับผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะ
ไม่เลือกหนังที่คะแนนดีๆอือ่าสมมุติบางคน
ชอบใช่มยคะว่าไปเช็คก่อนอ้อเว็บไซต์ใน
เอ่อ rotten  Tomato ว่าสมมุติอยากจะดู
คบิอย่างเงี้ยอู้คบิ
ได้ 90 คะแนน 90% คนเนี่ยเนี่ยชอบคุณหญิง
ก็อาจจะคิดอืมดูไม่ดูดีนะอ่าแต่ถ้าได้
คิวบิวได้ประมาณ 30 คะแนนครับผู้หญิงอ้า
ู้หญิงน่าจะดูได้
อืเพราะว่ารู้สึกว่าเพราะว่าครูนิกจะชอบ
ดูหนังที่ต้องคิดใช่มั้ยคะใช่อ่าคือครู
หญิงไม่ค่อยดูไงรู้สึกเหมือนเราดูถ้าหนัง
ดีมากๆอ่ะได้ออ้า
เหมือน Green  Book หรอหรือโน้ตบุ๊ค Green
Book มันจะมีหนังเรื่องนึงที่ผู้ชาย
โน้ตบุ๊กใช่มั้ยเออคุณหญิงไม่แน่ใจว่ามัน
ชื่อเรื่องอะไรอ่ะค่ะที่ผู้ชายผิวขาวเขา
เป็นคนขับรสให้กับผู้ชายผิวดำอ่ะดังมากๆ
คิดว่าได้ออสการผู้หญิงไม่แน่ใจว่ากีนโนต
Green  Book เพราะว่าถ้าโน้ตบุ๊คเนี่ยจะ
เป็นหนังเกี่ยวกับผู้ชายผู้หญิง
ชอบกันแต่อเค้าอยู่คนละฐานะคือถ้าจำไม่
ผิดผู้หญิงเป็นรวยผู้ชายไม่ใช่คนรวยใช่หิ
ไม่แน่ใจว่าไม่ใช่กรีนแดงว่าใช่ครับ Green
Book ครับ Green อๆๆใช่ๆค่ะชื่อเรื่อง
ว่า Green  Book  Green  Book ใช่ครับเออ
เนี่ยค่ะอย่างเงี้ยเดี๋ยวเปิดให้ดูนะคะ
นักเรียนครับคือแบบนี่ค่ะเรื่องนี้เห็น
มั้ยได้คิดว่าได้ออสการนะชนะรางวัลออสการ
นะคะอย่างเงี้ยค่ะก็คุหญิงเนี่ยน่าจะไม่
ดูนะคะเพราะว่าคิดว่าถ้าดูแล้วก็จะนั่ง
แบบอะไรอ่ะเออ
ใช่จริงๆเนี่ยหนังหนังรางวัลน่ะมันจะคือ
เมื่อก่อนนะครูนิกจะคิดว่าก็เนี่ยพวกหนัง
ออสการเนี่ยได้ออสการเพราะมันเพราะว่าคุณ
นิก็จะพูดเล่นกับเพื่อนว่าก็เนี่ยได้
ออสการ์เพราะมันงงๆไงก็เพราะคนที่ให้
คะแนนน่ะก็คือถ้าหนังเรื่องเยงงเยอะๆ
เนี่ยก็เอารางวัล
ไปแต่พอครูดิ๊กเนี่ยได้ดูเอ่อหนัง
ฝรั่งเศสแล้วมันเปลี่ยนใช่มั้ยโอเปลี่ยน
เลยเปลี่ยนเลยเออตอนครั้งแรกที่ดูมันจะงง
แต่พอครั้งต่อไปเราจะเข้าใจมากขึ้นว่าอ
อ๋อเพราะแต่ละที่เนี่ยวัฒนธรรมมันไม่
เหมือนกัน
แล้วเอาจริงๆเนี่ยที่คุณนิกเคยได้ยินก็
คือคนที่ยุโรปเนี่ยเขาจะไม่ชอบดูหนัง
ฮอลลีวูดอืใช่ผู้หญิงก็เคยได้ยินหนัง
ฮอลลีวูดเนี่ยมันไม่ได้ใช้ความคิดมันไม่
เป็นอาร์ตใช่มยใช่คือคนจะรู้เลยว่า
โอ๊ยก็เนี่ยเดี๋ยวพอเป็นแบบเนี้ยเดี๋ยวก็
กลับมาแล้วเดี๋ยวมันก็เป็นแบบคือคนจะเดา
ได้ว่าเดี๋ยวต่อไปจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นอใช่ค่ะ
อืใช่เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยก็เป็นคนดูหนัง
ที่คือถ้าอย่างครูหญิงดูหนังก็คือเลือก
หนังที่ดูแล้วเรารู้สึกแบบอ่าเราไปทำงาน
มาเนี่ยโอ้เครียดมากดูหนังแล้วสบายๆ่แต่
คุหญิงก็มีน้องที่รู้จักอ่ะค่ะที่เหมือน
ครูนิกอ่ะเขาชอบดูหนังดูทุกเรื่องหนังดีๆ
เนี่ยเขาคก็จะไปดูแล้วแบบอู้อันนี้ดีมาก
เหมือนเคดูแบบฉากดูซีนอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเขาค
ก็เลือกนะคือบางคนก็อาจจะเลือกจากผู้
กำกับใช่มแบบใช่คงรู้จักแบบสตีเฟนสลบนี่
เค้าเป็นผู้กำกับมั้ยคะใช่ๆเป็นผู้กำกับ
ครับหรือว่าคริสโตเฟอร์แล่นมั้ยดังๆคนไทย
รู้จักอ่าครับคือจริงๆ
อ่ะคุณนิเนี่ยเป็นคนจำชื่อคนไม่เก่งต้อง
เห็นหน้าครูนิกก็เลยแบบผู้กำกับเนี่ย
โอ้โหไม่ต้องพูดถึงไม่เคยเห็นหน้าผู้
กำกับอยู่แล้วไม่เคยไม่เคยใช่ๆค่ะถ้าเห็น
หน้าก็ไม่รู้แต่ถ้าชื่อแบบกำกับหนัง
ฮอลลีวูดที่คนไทยแบบชอบดูอย่างเงี้ยอ
ไมเคิลเบมยไมเคิลเบยังไม่รู้จักเลยใครคือ
ไมเคิเบทฟรหรือเปล่าเดี๋ยวครูหญิงพูดไป
นักเรียนบอกครูหญิงไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ก็อ่ะ
อย่างหนังเนี่ยหนังอย่างเดียวที่ครูนิไม่
ชอบดูคือหนังแอคชั่น
อืคุณนิจะไม่ชอบดูอย่างไม่อย่างอ่าง่ายๆ
แอคชั่นแล้วก็ไฟจะดูได้นิดหน่อยแต่อย่าง
เรื่อง Star  War ครูนิกไม่เคยดู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เลยไม่ได้นะคือคุณนิรู้จักนะ
เจไดแค่
นั้นไม่ว่าครูหญิงชอบ Star  Wars มากๆ
Star  Wars  Star  Trek นี่ชอบ
มาก Star เกกับเพื่อนครูนิก็ชอบมากๆชอบจน
แบบพอเวลาครูนิกไปบ้านเพื่อนเพื่อนก็บอก
อ้าเดี๋ยววันนี้จะดู Star  Trek นะคือคุณ
เออก็ได้วะเฮ้ย Star เทคสนุกนะก็ไม่แย่
ถ้าเป็นซีรียส์เก่าๆนะอ่าอๆซีรียส์ก็อืนะ
คือนักเรียนได้ดูวีดีโอนี้นะคะนักเรียนก็
รู้แล้วว่าออครูหญิงกับครูนิกไปดูหนัง
ด้วยกันไม่ได้ยกเว้นครูนิดู Mer  streep
อ่ะครูหญิงดูได้ดู
ได้เนาะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะเวลานักเรียนจะ
เลือกดูหนังดูซีรียส์นักเรียนเลือกจาก
อะไรเนาะเหมือนครูนิกหรือว่าเหมือนครู
หญิงไหมนะก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้ครับได้แต่
ตอนนี้หมดเวลาได้ค่ะงั้นเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอ
กันใหม่วดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีครับ